[Music]
it brings me great sadness that it has
come to this
there really was no other option there
have been reports that harry and megan
have asked for an extension
to this year probation and actually my
understanding is that this is not
the case apart from the military titles
there are very
few outstanding issues but the general
consensus is
that this divorce has worked
megan and harry left the royal family
become financially independent
and they have absolutely achieved that
this year so
was mexit worth it well that reported
150 million
deal with netflix says it was harry and
megan used that check to buy their 14.6
million dollar montecito mansion and
pay back the british taxpayers for the
renovations on frogmore cottage
judging by their happy family holiday
card there are no regrets
the sussexes have also been quick to
brag about how well archie's adjusting
revealing the 20 month old is already
talking
and with an american accent after me
ready
happy happy new year
but one royal fail the debut of their
archwell podcast was bested by a show
that featured whale noise sleep sounds
i don't think they're going to be too
bothered that it only ranked
13 i mean they managed to get sir elton
john on their first podcast that's
pretty impressive and
my understanding is that they're very
pleased with how it's gone
on the plus side harry's rift with
william has mended a bit since the
pandemic and coveted permitting the
sussex clan could attend prince philip's
100th birthday celebration in june
and stay for an event to honor harry's
late mother in july
the much awaited statue tribute
to princess diana will be unveiled in
kensington palace gardens on what would
have been
diana's 60th birthday and it is harry's
intention
and megan's also to be here in the uk
for that opening and it's possible that
2021 could bring harry and megan
another child megan wrote very bravely
about the miscarriage that they suffered
in the summer so we know that
that they were trying um for a second
baby
and you know i'm sure they're hoping
very much that this will be the year
when archie gets to have a little
brother or a little sister